[Applause]
[Music]
so delighted to be here with all of you
tonight
to engage one of my favorite people in
conversation dr. Zach we met a couple
years ago yeah I remember it vividly we
were at a conference not on like this
and we had this amazing conversation it
was completely unlike this was actually
a friendship was born and we have gone
on to have some of the most meaningful
and impactful conversations I've ever
had in my life
and so it's a pleasure and an honor to
be I'm here tonight to help share a
little bit of that with everybody here
so welcome and thank you I'm beyond
honored to be here it's been
overwhelming sitting through two days of
these this caliber of human beings and
the whole time thinking you're supposed
to follow all that it's just really
after that it's fair are you kidding me
yeah what are we doing up there
I don't I don't have any music videos
not one we can work on that so zach is a
triple board-certified physician which
is a rare thing endocrinology and
metabolism internal medicine and hospice
and palliative care
correct right hold it nailed it yeah but
that's the least of what makes you
unusual in my mind you're a very
unconventional medical practitioner and
I'm interested I think a good place to
start would be to walk us through this
evolution from being somebody who was
reared in the conventional medical
school paradigm into what I would
characterize as a more more of a healer
than
yeah I think the seeds are always
planted in our lives that we don't
necessarily realize what they're
planting I think this last discussion
that we just heard with these vignettes
of a woman's life that she recalls these
poignant and painful moments and now
here she is you know as a source of
wisdom for Humanity through the
collection of these seeds that are
planted and I feel like you know any of
us could tell that same story of our
lives we had these seeds planted and
wisdom comes out of pain wisdom comes
out of loss somehow heart opens through
heartbreak all of these you know weird
dichotomies that happen in life and for
me setting me up for that what would I
had no idea that would be a transition
from you know inside the box allopathic
pharmaceutical doctor to a quack that
early learning was really around just my
nuclear family a wonderful parents
incredible mom and dad grew up in
low-income housing in Boulder and it's
so interesting to remember back what it
was used to be like a kid you don't you
didn't know what you looked like
right it's so interesting how bombarded
our children are today with what they
look like I mean they're selfing all the
time they have this vision I was but in
the late 60s and early 70s there weren't
full-length mirrors at least not in
low-income housing and so when you're
three feet tall you literally don't have
access to anything that would give you a
reflection of yourself and and so I
think I went through this wonderful
point of life where I didn't know what I
looked like I just know what it felt
like to be me and a lot of what shaped
that was my mother had an intractable
seizure disorder a lot of epilepsy when
I was growing up and so it was not an
unusual scenario where we'd be at a
grocery store and she'd start having a
grand mal seizure and all the other
taller people you don't even think of
yourself as a kid right when your kids
just like you're the short and they all
these big people around you and all the
big people would start freaking out and
I would just sit down with my mom and
put her in you know sit next to her head
and and hold her hand or whatever until
the seizure and so that planet is seated
me I think of just like this awareness
that to be with somebody who's in
distress or having a crisis you just
have to be present and it's a powerful
thing and I would see all the big people
settle down when I showed them that I
wasn't scared and I knew how to take
care of my mom and she having seizure
that happened and and much more of life
kind of unfolded in the years to come
that took me way far away from the
concept of medicine I didn't know that I
was gonna be good at medicine I I
consider myself kind of a B+ student a
terrible test taker terrible guests are
like if it was a multiple-choice test I
was always like I'm going to fail this
thing hated multiple-choice tests didn't
do well with a lot of aspects of school
so I just got into auto mechanics and so
I built cars and tore cars apart with
all my buddies and that was like what I
thought I was gonna do but through one
of those seasons planted the first
girlfriend when I was very cool 18 years
old or something like that and his first
girlfriend ends up breaking my heart in
a number of ways as if you can really
have your heart broken by a girl when
you're 18 but when you're 18 you're like
I'm just devastated and I'm just like
blown open I'm so dramatic and and so in
that drama moment I decided I wasn't
gonna go into my engineering program at
cu-boulder and I was gonna go just
traveller world and figure myself out
kind of thing and within like minutes of
that decision an aunt called up and was
like you want to come to the Philippines
and birth babies and I was like whoa
that's like totally tripping cool yeah
that sounds really interesting no
medical experience didn't actually had a
vague idea what babies were as the
oldest of three kids as like they kind
of come out and they turn into siblings
and so I was like I have some experience
I was like seeing three of
things grow up seeing and I've seen them
yeah and I hadn't really I don't think
ever really held when I think maybe I
held my my littlest brother when he was
first born but got to the Philippines is
19 incredible experience and over those
next six months all some of the most
mind-blowing things saying the Rowdy is
none of you would be sitting here right
now listening to any of us if you could
really wrap your mind around how
miraculous you are there's there's just
no way you would bother listening to
anybody because what could anybody add
to that miracle this woman sitting here
this is beauty this woman here has 70
trillion cells and inside every one of
those cells is six feet of DNA and if we
strung her DNA and to end this beautiful
woman here would wrap around mother
earth two million times wrap around
mother earth two million times and you
have been knit together to live the life
you've lived to touch the hands you've
touched to hug the the people you've
hugged to kiss the faces you've kissed
and to do what you've done
who could add to anything like that
we are literal numerical miracles
walking around and I got to see that in
the Philippines and I watched in the
most extreme poverty I'd ever been
exposed to
babies being born out of women who had
nothing with such genuine hope and
expectation of life and these tiny
little babies four pound babies you know
they can fit in your hand and then they
go on to thrive and so that all of that
planted a seed so that when allopathic
medicine came along and said
here's two thousand diseases here's two
thousand drugs to treat those diseases
go do it I went after that I was gonna
totally go do that but when it didn't
work when it started to fail eight years
in I had those seeds of remembering to
be really a great presence in somebody's
life whose suffering and whose brain is
totally dysfunctioning just be still
silent and sitting next to them it's
enough or witness a freaking miracle at
any stage of life realized that whatever
ridiculous training you might have can't
add to that you can only be witness to
that and so that set the stage and I
still had no idea where that was gonna
take me but I was willing to start to
close the door on the allopathic world
realizing I could study that the rest of
my life I could get three more
subspecialties because that's why I got
three subspecialties I was looking for
truth I was looking for some solid
ground to stand on but during this
period of time in which you're fully
immersed in allopathic medicine you're
practicing within the Western paradigm
diagnosed prescribed was there a
specific incident that made you realize
you needed to course-correct or change
your trajectory was or was it an
evolution over time of what you were
seeing on a daily basis like who was
coming into your office what were you
seeing and what triggered you to change
this approach to healing and medicine it
was an evolution and there was triggers
that I think you know a couple of those
events I was studying cancer developing
chemotherapy at the time that was my
research world and then clinically as an
endocrinologist I've seen a lot of
diabetes autoimmune disease alike and
there was a moment where I was watching
out of the microscope cancer cells
infiltrating healthy tissue and all of
you have actually seen a this exact
image many many times all of you have
flown so you could get to Nantucket and
when you're flying and you're flying
over a large city and you see the way in
which highways shoot out from the cities
and then we or
housing and you know infrastructure
around that is exactly the same shape as
a cancer growing into healthy tissue and
so when you see something like Dallas
Texas growing into the the nature around
it it looks for all the world as a
cancer would grow exactly the same thing
following the arterioles of blood supply
nutrients nervous systems of
communication and so I was staring out
this experiencing this and then ran over
to the clinic and jumped into my white
coat put on a stethoscope so it looked
like I knew what I was talking about and
then jumped into this seat and this guy
can't who I'd never seen before
was sitting on the other side it's like
are you in the wrong clinic I'm dr.
Busch I don't think I've met you and
he's like well I just had a really
urgent problem anyway he pulls up his
pant leg and he's got this diabetic
ulcer in the side of his leg that's just
horrible like just losing all kinds of
horrible gross stuff and so I get down
in this after wagger than all the
equipment together started to breathing
and just clearing out this all sir just
try to get this guy stabilized until he
can have a definitive surgery or
something like that and there came a mom
when I was scraping away at this healthy
tissue and suddenly there was the exact
same image of this necrotic dead
diabetic ulcer sitting in the midst of
this healthy tissue looked exactly like
the cancer and at that moment suddenly
realized I wonder if we were just
calling these things a bunch of
different names and in fact it's all the
same freakin thing what if there's just
lack of healthy tissue and then you
develop disease and that sounds so
freaking obvious but it was very
profound to a mind that had a belief
that disease is kind of snuck up on you
and infiltrated your system and you
could get infections or you could get
cancer or you get you know autoimmune
diseases and they sneak up on you and
the realization that we would we would
make vulnerabilities within our body for
these things to come and take up space
was just flipped it all on its head yeah
it's almost in a perspective that's
rooted in Ayurveda in that the the body
has a certain balance that it's trying
to strike and when that
balance is out of whack or certain
systems are out of balance you create
the opportunity for certain diseases
like this to appear exactly right and I
think that that ends up being you fast
forward my clinic that I run is called
the M clinic we picked the letter M
because it's the center of all of the
spoken and written alphabets as a letter
in it and so I figured it must represent
the the balance point of communication
and had by this time decided that all
disease is created or the opportunity
for disease created by a lack of
communication and so that we could find
a center point of communication around
the letter M and then find out that
bizarrely that will sound of mmm is the
sound of creation and so the ohm that we
create and so what if the sound of
creation was the center point of
communication and so that all kinds of
fascinating things about that M in
addition to or one of them being that
it's the only letter that represents the
masculine and the feminine and so that's
kind of you just nailed it in that
Ayurveda 5,000 years of Chinese medicine
as well all of these have been speaking
of balance and there is not a single
pharmaceutical drug you can take that
puts you into balance it is an
inherently man-made artificial chemical
therefore was able to be patented and
turned into a multibillion-dollar drug
that drug as it enters your body is a
foreign invader it's going to create
imbalance at every level it's why every
commercial for a drug has to have 15
seconds of disclaimer at the end spoken
very quickly it says it's going to cause
erectile dysfunction acne and death but
at least your blood pressure would be
good you know and so yeah that the
reality is we are creating imbalance by
looking at human beings as a source of
disease rather than a vessel for health
right the difference between the
paradigm of diagnose and prescribe a
disease model versus the study of what
what what what are the pinnacles of
health like what constitutes how
with a capital H so how do you define
health health is defined simply at its
lowest or most common denominator as
fully connected to nature if a cell is
fully connected to its nature and has
unfettered access to information it will
forever be healthy you can injure it all
day long you can give it radiation and
it will repair at an insane rate now and
if you got so lucky as to repair it and
injure it so badly couldn't repair
itself it would simply commit suicide
through apoptosis our program sells
suicide and in the process calling a
stem cell to replace it it's literally
an infinite source of life is a healthy
cell and that's so health in the end is
are you completely connected to your
nature and do you have unfettered access
information yeah it's beautifully put
and I think telescoping out from that I
want to get into the relationship
between human health and environmental
health like we tend to think of human
health in isolation under a microscope
under this sort of you know binary
perspective of scientific inquiry but
much of what you talk about and much of
your focus is on looking at the holistic
nature of this environment within which
you know that we that we share within
which we live
so talk a little bit about the
relationship between environmental
degradation and the escalation of some
of these chronic illnesses that we're
seeing at disproportionate rates right
now yeah to believe this information was
we can back up for a moment to a huge
topic that's blown up for the last ten
years which is the microbiome and the
microbiome has become a catchphrase
that's even in your you know women's
journals on the next to the grocery
store line everything else you don't
have to go to medical literature and the
more to hear about the microbiome
it's really telling because dove just
came out with a so dove friendly to the
microbiome huh if if that's what your
shampoo bottle says now that means that
we no longer in a scientific description
of microbiome it is now a fad so
friendly to the microbiome soap is not
true like that that's just not how soap
works and so we can ignore that little
factoid and just take it as the whole
population has come to embrace the
concept of the microbiome unfortunately
neither doctors in order the consumer
has any idea what the microbiome really
is it's just a vague sense of whether
there's lots of good bacteria and the
leap forward there was of course the
probiotic probiotic industry which turns
out as a scientific disaster a medical
disaster it was 37 billion dollar
marketing campaign there's not good
science behind the probiotic industry
but all of that said at least it broke
the door open to the possibility that
there was good bacteria out there
because up until the probiotics we
really there was this manifest you know
just belief that all bacteria were bad
and so you saw the burst of anti
microbial everything right yeah anti
microbial baby wipes yet into microbial
alcohol pumps every time you walk into
the grocery store before you touch that
grocery cart you got a anti microbial
wipe and you're wiping that off and so
we developed you know over over a
hundred and twenty years we developed a
belief that bacteria we're gonna attack
us and kill us bacteria it turns out are
just the very tip of the iceberg of this
thing we call the microbiome it is the
microbial life that creates soil it
secretes the air we breathe it creates
the bodies that we thrive in it's
certainly we all come to understood
constitutes the gut right and so the the
bacteria of your small intestine and
colon but yep bacteria all through your
sinuses through the mouth and oral
structures all of your skin under your
eyelids but the bacteria you've got
about twenty or thirty thousand species
on a human body some people think it's
gonna be maybe 40 50 that's a lot of
species and then you see how many of
those species you find out that this
woman has 70 trillion cells as pointed
out but she's carrying her
it's 1.5 quadrillion bacteria that's
incredible but the bacteria are
outnumbered
another tenfold by parasites and
parasites there's 300,000 species of the
parasites we fear and we think oh you
don't want to get a parasite you go to
India you're probably to get a parasite
bah bah so they have this concept that
parasites are somehow over in India and
you know no there's 300 thousand species
of parasite they probably are right
there certainly indeed yeah they just
travel through seasonally but no they
there's actually parasites everywhere
and there's these cool little parasites
that live under every healthy eyelid
that looks a little like a worm with
this freaky face on it and without that
guy living on your eyelid you're
actually a very prone to disease and so
we have a well that's yesterday say
something friendly to your eyelid worms
tonight
and so the parasites again are
outnumbered radically by the fungi and
so we now are estimating around 5
million species of fungi you go to your
Trader Joe's and you see that you've got
moisture mushrooms and shiitake or like
a nice grocery store through three
species of fungi now there's five
million species of fungi we're
scratching the surface with our culinary
adventures five million species of fungi
when you start to really calculate that
up you start to realize how vastly
outnumbered the humanity is were one
species and Homo sapiens sapiens we
named herself wise twice which I think
just as inherently unwise like at some
point that same state rated like any
rate Homo sapiens sapiens we would
decode at our genome and found that
there was 20,000 genes and that's
horribly bad news for a wide species
because shortly before we decoded the
human genome we found out the fruit fly
had 13,000 genes and we had found out
that the flea had 30,000 genes and so to
find out the human falls somewhere
between a flea and a fruit fly frankly a
little close to the fruit fly
seemed like we got a real short deck
it's like we were expecting 280 thousand
genes and we had 20 and so this was like
1996 1998 blew apart the whole concept
of genome and DNA because suddenly we
realized we were wrong because Watson
and Crick found the double helix and we
had known what a gene was and that gene
could go on to make one RNA which would
go on to make one protein and we knew we
had 280 thousand different proteins and
so surely we had to have enough genes to
make all of the human body and to find
out that we were that missing of genomic
data sent us back to the drawing board
and suddenly we had created this whole
new belief of epigenetics and
epigenetics became this understanding
that each gene could be manipulated to
create different outcomes meaning an
imagined a blueprint of a house being
able to build 200 different houses and
that's exactly how it turns out and so
each gene in your body you've got 20,000
but each of those two now make over 200
different gene products depending on
your environment and so by 2000 we were
starting to realize when we are super
plastic and we get these genes from mom
we get these genes from dad and then
from there on out the ecology plays with
them the ecology is manipulating and
moving that what you're going to become
if you do the math each one of you with
the genes that you got from mom and dad
could put out 4 million different
variants of you depending on your
environment yeah and then this gets more
crazy because recently we found out that
there's 98% of your genome I mentioned
that this woman wraps around Mother
Earth 2 million times it's kind of
mind-blowing amount of DNA that DNA that
wraps around Earth 2 2 million times
98.5 percent of it does not code for a
gene and so we very obviously came to
the clear conclusion that that was junk
DNA lots of waste because when you look
out at nature it's just like 98.5
percent junk everywhere just waste waste
waste but we didn't know what it was we
called it junk DNA and then just in the
last couple of years we find out that
that 98.5 percent of the gene
is actually coding for these tiny little
nucleotide sequences that we call micro
RNA now that do something very crazy for
genetic information is that they leave
the cell and so your genome starts to
permeate the space around the cell that
would have the nucleus that contained
this chromosome that held the DNA and
it's now leaking out of that cell and
the micro RNA is now permeating your
whole body it got crazier though when we
realized that the micro RNA wasn't even
contained to the body and it could leave
in in the the little back hills within
this life of my mouth and suddenly I
could it could go airborne in the air
that I breathe out and that micro RNA is
being breathed in by all of you and so I
have genetically modified every one of
you you guys are all leaving as GMOs
yeah every one of you is a genetically
modified organism and the one I'm having
the most influence on you is the one
you're swapping saliva with the most and
interestingly it's not just the human
there that's creating that that shift
the micro RNA go on to determine what
genes are gonna turn on in these vastly
different spaces and so you could turn
on genes different than you would have
if I hadn't shown up and so you're
genetically responding to me and that's
fascinating because in that journey
we're realizing I'm ten to one bacteria
to human and if we looked at this
woman's blood stream right now we'd find
out that forty percent of the genetic
micro RNA switches in her bloodstream
isn't even human it's bacteria fungi and
the microbiomes information turning this
woman into somebody different and so
that's where we ran into this collision
of moments that you just asked about
which is as we destroy ecology and we
find out that ecology is modifying the
human genome there's got to be a crisis
point where the human genome can no
longer produce intelligent health and we
run into this zero point of destruction
of biology on the planet and a great
extinction occurs mmm-hmm he had to
ground this in the themes of
of tnp connectivity community
communication you know at a very top
level you're dealing with these very
same subject matters on the micro level
so when we consider the fact that we are
much more micro organism than we are
human that we are breathing out this RNA
and we are literally connecting
ourselves to our community in a very
unconscious way I think for me what that
does is it it helps me to realize that
that we're not as sentient as we think
we are and that are our survival and our
ability to thrive is so deeply
interconnected to everything that
surrounds us and you know I've heard you
speak about treating patients with all
the right things lifestyle diet etc and
not getting results and coming to this
conclusion that the reason you weren't
seeing these results was because the
food was being sourced from soil that
was depleted and the point being that we
cannot isolate ourselves out of our
environment and treat these conditions
in isolation we have to consider
everything in the whole and disease as a
function of a lack of communication and
connectivity and the journey towards
health is what we've been speaking about
all weekend which is about embracing
community and growing closer to not just
our environment but the people that we
love and the new people that we're
bringing into our lives and this is what
is happening on a cellular level
that's exactly accurate I believe I
think it's fascinating to think that
here we are each of you sitting next to
each other are genomically enriching one
another
you're changing each other genetically
and so there's a there's an invisible
communication network going on in this
room
that doesn't happen on a zoom conference
that doesn't happen across a Twitter
feed and so it's interesting to think as
we digitize human communication
we're losing genetic swapping we're
becoming genetically isolated as
beings as we lose touch as we lose
face-to-face communication by the way
every time I talk to you for a couple of
hours I always try to go run faster the
next day because I just hope I breathe
than the right RNA I keep I'm the
subject of human touch who here is has
received a hug from Zack over the last
couple days he's a pretty amazing he
likes to hug for a long time but go
ahead it's it's it's my version of
highway robbery like I'm just like
genomically sucking you in and you're
like that's a long hug I'm like that's a
really freaking short genetic infusion
no that's really good stuff so
communicating by touch is interesting
but it gets really weird now that we're
looking beyond the genomics now let's
let's go into the human gut and so this
woman here another beautiful woman it's
really nice to be arrayed around around
stage with beautiful people all around I
got to say this is a really unique thing
because often times is you're looking
out at lights and you just see a dark
audience so thank you for whoever
designed this room this is the most
beautiful speaking experience I've had
just cuz I can see each of you so wow
this woman has an intestinal membrane
all of you do this isn't supposed to be
like a gross thing about her
she has an intestinal membrane that
covers two tennis courts and surface
area and it looks like a coral reef and
so if we put all of your intestines
together I'm really big into macro
examples because just most of these
things don't make any sense on the micro
level but if we put all of your
intestinal linings together right now we
could cover that entire Bay in human
intestine and it's a fascinating coral
reef that looks just like a coral reef
with all these fingers that ornately
reach out to suck nutrients out of the
ocean you're sucking nutrients out of
the food that you just ingested in the
last couple hours and you're becoming
enriched by this experience and your
colon is sucking water your colon sole
job is to suck water out of your your
nutritional input that's fascinating so
the water is just as important if not
the most important part of consumption
of nutrients so you need a cucumber and
you absorb all those micronutrients from
the small intestine and then the water
from that cucumber sucked in by the
colon and you end up with this hyper
intelligence that's been sucked out of
there because along that journey the
microbes have changed every nutrient
changed the whole experience and what
we're now finding is we're getting
better better doing micro imaging of the
gut lining is that the neurons that
innervate you that to test quartz and
surface area have to be so numerous for
one part then the number of nerves in a
single human intestinal lining
constitutes the size of a dog's brain
and so it's a massive neural center that
is your gut and so this whole concept
that every woman knows is the way to a
man's brain is through his stomach is
actually know that is his brain like
it's not like Roo there you get to the
brain like that's the brain and so you
get to the brain and it's so interesting
how fast that happens because we've now
been able to image that the human
neurons are reaching up to the
intestines largely to get serotonin and
dopamine serotonin and we think of as
being this brain neurochemical but it
turns out that 90 percent of the
serotonin made in the human body is made
in the gut lining
enteric endocrine cells that little
Ghostbuster looking greens globules that
are they are there cranking out
serotonin the nerves reach up and grab
all that information and then we just
found out just in the last couple years
that your enteric endocrine system can't
make serotonin if you don't have the
right bacteria sitting on top of that
human cell and so it takes a it takes a
bacteria to inform a human endocrine
cell to make the neurons to go into the
brain but then it got weirder that ucsf
just showed that the brain actually
sends neurons past the gut lining itself
right into the [ __ ] like this is so
bizarre like you're now thinking [ __ ]
all the time you're just like encased in
this milieu of great poop and the
origins of life you can imagine there
than thousands of species of bacteria
and fungi and parasites and nutrients
composting at high speeds and your brain
wanted to know what that was going on
there so just grew neurons into that at
the same time same journal actually
published that the ion channel in the
surface of those particular neurons are
totally different than the ion channels
in the brain they actually designed the
human neuron designed its ion channels
to mimic the design of the ion channels
on the surface of the bacteria your gut
what I'm describing is you asked what is
this
Nantucket project version of human
anatomy as we now understand it and the
answer is the neighborhood is not human
the neighborhood is hundreds of
thousands of species with a genome
that's so much more vast than ours and a
neuro chemistry that's active straight
to our brain as we start to study the
brain more and more we realize there is
no center of memory for long-term memory
in the human brain totally bizarre if
the brain doesn't store your long term
memory where is that stored
okay so you got a hard drive somewhere
you've got some RAM we've just the
hippocampus is tiny little area of the
brain that
that short-term memory stick of the
computer but where the hard drive sits
nobody knows and so I mean I do
obviously but most people don't and so
and so you've got the situation where
you realize this is just the central
processing unit it's not the hardware of
and the CPU chip of your computer the
CPU has never written a term paper or a
book interesting the CPU chip in your
computer's actually never created a
piece of data or information all it is
is the central processing unit the brain
looks to be only a central processing
unit it can't have a taste it can't have
a smell it can't have a thought it can't
have anything it's just the CPU chip it
then sends out wires and so you've got
sitting on your desk a keyboard which
did write the tarrant term paper no
keyboard has never written a term paper
the keyboard just sits there until
somebody comes and types a thought into
that keyboard and then all those digits
digital signals go to the CPU chip and
process that and now you can print
something we're now finding out that the
fingers typing on your keyboard are not
human fingers the microbiome is
literally typing on a toot escort
surface area keyboard to tell your brain
what's going on and what it should think
I feel like that should depress me I
don't know how to take that information
but what I gather have a thought yeah I
waiting for my I'm supposed to switch
seats here right let's do that
let me get wrap my head around what you
just said what I take from that is that
we are less human than we would like to
believe that we are I know there are
studies that track the relationship
between the nature of our microbiome
and the foods that we crave or the
impulses that we entertain and these are
things that we like to think were
consciously creating or unconsciously
creating but which are innately human
and to discover that they are not begs
the question of the nature of
consciousness itself right from whence
does consciousness arise and is human
consciousness something that can be
characterized or defined as individuated
or is it something more pervasive and
elusive that has its roots and its
nature in this community of
microorganisms that permeates all I
think you just nailed it I'm asking you
a question
[Laughter]
isn't it so typical of a species that
calls itself homeless Homo sapiens
sapiens
- then coined the term human
consciousness as if the CPU chip ever
wrote the paper right as if the human
brain would ever create consciousness I
really at this stage of especially in my
hospice work it's the most obvious it at
this second birth that we have which is
often termed death which is really bad
PR manager and better marketing for
death is definitely rebirth and the
longer you do hospice work and the more
times you get to sit at the bedside of
somebody who's who's in this
transformation event the last
transformation they get to do in this
body they're now doing in front of your
eyes and they do some crazy wonderful
stuff
they will say some of the most profound
stuff you've ever heard they will say
some of the most vulnerable things
you've ever heard and they will
definitely bring to clarity the value
that their life has had regardless of
how worthless they thought their life
was up until that moment during that
transformation they see value in their
life and you see it all stripping away
and it's at the moment that their neuro
chemistry is literally shutting down
their brain has failed
and at that moment they light you up
with this consciousness this conscious
awareness that's just blindingly cool
this this moment of clarity only coming
when they let go of their firmly held
belief system that is human they're
firmly health held beliefs of their
roles and their purpose in their
community and the the identity that
they've allowed that world to create for
them finally starts to inevitably fall
apart as the neuro chemistry and the
heart starts to fail and everything
shutting down and that's when they get
the most clarity they've ever had and
what is how do you characterize that
clarity what is that clarity it is
consciousness at its at its raw state
the human is dissolving and the
consciousness is just there it's been
there the whole time
but the human
can you imagine what we do as parents
can you imagine what we do as a society
these infants are born out of this
infinite potential of life and they come
springing out with 70 trillion cells and
connected to some sort of soul that has
a purpose that's picked this path and
picked their whole journey is laid out
before them and then within minutes we
start programming them we start
deprogramming them of truth and beauty
and the miracle fact that they are alive
and start tagging them with information
I'm your dad you believe you're a dad
until you have a second kid and then
you're suddenly like I have nothing to
do with this thing right my son was like
so radical when he was born as it's like
he literally freaked us out like he came
out with his hands crossed like this and
eyes wide open he's like already wiser
than I was and I was pretty young when I
had him like I'd like to tell people I
was like 4 when I had him because he's
21 now and it freaks me out
but he's now I watch him go from that to
the human being is and he's got this
preternatural like age to him from the
day one and then I had my daughter and
she's just like this like bundle of joy
just like enthusiasm joy wants to talk
about nothing terribly serious and
doesn't want to get too deep on anything
but wants to just be a source of joy for
the world that's when you realize the
only thing I can do as a parent is
really screw this thing up because I
don't know where this thing came from
and I don't know where it's heading and
I have no idea why it showed up and so
at that point you should really take
this massive dose of humility and just
be like I just need to create some safe
space around this thing the best of my
ability and I'm just gonna like try to
feed it a couple times a day
stand back and see what happens cuz I
can't do much more help to that and that
that technique has worked pretty well so
I call it kind of like unparent
announced coolers but just unpair it's
just stay out of the way and these
things come out and then it takes them a
whole freakin lifetime to realize that
they're not a Sun they're not a daughter
they're not an aunt or an uncle or a
grandparent or an employee or a boss or
a CEO or a garbage man or whatever thing
we layered this up and then it takes a
whole lifetime to start to try to drill
down through all those layers of human
that we put on top of raw miracle and
the consciousness that's sitting there
that whole time I think is just begging
for attention and all of us get those
conscious moments the poets that have
shared with us this week you guys are
tapping into consciousness and it's not
cumin it's not him and you say things
that are too trippy to be human your
your some more alien than you are human
we should talk about aliens in other
times good subject but right now we're
in the microbiome and so you're you
start to realize console on the
microbiome yeah well you know you got to
stay rooted where you're at so you go
stay in the soil stand the dirt you
gotta stay in the [ __ ]
and so the microbiome is always there to
inform the consciousness until human
behavior comes along to inflict itself
on the microbiome and we started doing
this in the late 1800s Luis Pasteur
became famous for pasteurization and so
we started pasteurizing our food to kill
all the bacteria in the food was the
idea in the late eighteen hundreds of
course now you can't buy almonds that
haven't been pasteurized as ridiculously
we try to annihilate all bacteria and
when we do that we wipe out the
consciousness that would be programming
your brain and so as we load the food
system with anti microbials herbicides
in particular and we grow an entire food
system that is steeped in a chemical
herbicide pesticide environment as soon
as you eat a piece of food now in fact
you don't have to eat food anymore we've
so in infiltrated the ecology with
herbicides and pesticides primary
number one chemical worldwide as far as
I'm concerned some around four and half
billion pounds when roughly last counted
in 2015 so we were doubling that rate
every six years and so maybe we were
between four and a half and six billion
pounds of this chemical which is
patented as an antibiotic not as a weed
killer and we pour that antibiotic into
the soils and it happens to be water
soluble and so again sucked up in the
water systems of our planet and we start
to see it evaporated in the air and now
75 percent of the air we breathe the
United States of contaminate we round up
the air we breathe and then it gets up
in a cloud and it rains back down 75
percent it rain we soak in is
contaminated with roundup and so it's
raining on us we're breathing it what
does that mean for the whole system it
means that the microbiome is being
crushed it's crushed in the air that we
should be breathing it's crushed at the
soil level it's crushed in the microbial
environment it's crushed in your gut the
ramifications for human consciousness if
we're going to call it that are pretty
significant we now know that one course
of antibiotics for a urinary tract
infection and a woman will increase her
risk of major depression by 24 percent
the next 12 months if she goes back in
to the doctor's office within that year
and gets a second course of antibiotics
maybe for bronchitis she now has a 54
percent increase and likely to major
depression in the next 12 months two
courses of antibiotics risk of anxiety
and panic attack goes up by 17 percent
with one course 44 percent with two
courses of antibiotic if you destroy the
microbiome your sense of connected
connectivity to the world around you
disappears loneliness literally results
from an antibiotic exposure and I want
you guys to be aware of this next time
somebody whacks you with an antibiotic
pay attention I want you to feel what it
feels like to disconnect from the
environment around you because a moment
before that if you got it last year you
would have just thought I'm depressed
now but now you go in consciously and
you get that experience you say I'm not
I'm just disconnected I'm just lonely
I just got isolated now it's not your
problem now this isn't a character flaw
depression is the result of isolation
loneliness at the cell level disconnect
from the micro biome and isn't it
amazing we find out the same thing about
cancer cancer we now understand is the
result of a disconnect from the micro
biome and it's very specific we now know
if you miss these bacteria in the gut
you're going to get breast cancer you
lose these bacteria you're gonna get
colon cancer lose these you get lung
cancer the microbiome is programming our
consciousness but it also is the
communication network of cellular repair
itself and so as you delete out the anti
microbial world we live in delete out
the microbiome isolation is inevitable I
believe we have created the phenomenon
Facebook and the phenomenon of Twitter
and the rest as an antidote to
antibiotics and the isolation that
resulted from them we would have never
seen the reason to connect through a
damn cell phone when we can simply look
look up at the person across the table
and talk but now you see kids it's not
unusual to see group of 16 kids outside
and these girls won't even look at their
friends they're with and their their
their snapchatting the girl that's right
in front of them that's how isolated and
lonely she feels she has brought lying
on this insane amount of Technology in
her hand to make this little human
connection of looking somebody in the
eye blessed the person who said look
each other in the eye yesterday whenever
that was
what a beautiful neurochemical event
happens when we look each other in the
eye and so we see cancer as the endpoint
of isolation a cancer cell has become so
isolated and lonely in its existence
that it doesn't even know that the rest
of the organism has survived it thinks
it's the last semblance of life in the
organism and the only thing it can do
now because it's so damaged it can't
repair the
which cancer cell has 20,000 genetic
unrepaired genetic injuries in it I
mentioned we only have 20,000 genes so
there's just injuries all over the
genome of a cancer cell
I can't repair itself so the last
semblance of life that it can do is
divided and so just starts dividing and
advising divides just saying life is
more important than anything else I find
it fascinating that a cell that thinks
everything else around it has died and
it's so injured that it cannot repair
still has a drive for life mm-hmm you
are but it's gonna take everyone else
down with it it doesn't know the same
way that it does damage human I hang my
who is connected and depressed right
isolated and lonely and then we dam that
guy who climbs the tower in Vegas and
shoots 250 strangers because he's the
cancer so at the macro level
he's so isolated that he doesn't even
understand he's part of a larger
organism called homo sapien he doesn't
understand that he's he's not alone and
he thinks he just needs to have an
emotional experience and so he's
creating this through a violent
outpouring this kid who walks into the
elementary school and starts shooting
his classmates is trying to induce an
experience in his body to just
experience something because it is so
numb in its isolation it is so quiet and
silent and isolated and lonely in its
isolation and so imagine if you walked
in with a new diagnosis of breast cancer
and the doctor just wrapped you up in a
giant [ __ ] hug and said you are
extraordinarily beautiful you are made
out of the fabric of life itself
you are drive for life at the fabric
level and now there's this tiny little
one cell out of your 70 trillion cells
that got so lonely and isolated that it
forgot or doesn't know that you still
are here and it still wants you to be
alive and so it's gonna start dividing
at all costs it's gonna try to stay
alive and now we just need to let that
cell know that it's part of a greater
community we need to let it plug back in
we need to reconnect that human cell and
it will stop being a cancer
yourself and that's exactly what we see
out of the microscope when you take a
human cell and you add back the
communication network of the microbiome
we extract these little communication
molecules they're literally we have the
great description of silicon today and
what the heck is Silicon Valley and all
this that description of silicon melted
down sand into that ore and it's sliced
thin and then we create microchips and
everything else turns out that the
bacteria and the fungi are making at the
molecular level a silicon base they're
making these tiny little carbon and not
silicon in this case it's carbon matrix
that can pass electrons through vast
distances they build liquid circuit
boards across biology so that it can
communicate and do brilliant
hyper-intelligent stuff this is what we
call quorum sensing in the microbiome
world where a single bacteria growing a
petri dish doesn't do anything much
intelligent it just eats and kind of
poops out some metabolites and just
grows and splits and splits but suddenly
when it starts the sense that the
community is that it's it's its proper
maximum number as it fills the petri
dish it sends out a global signal it
says we're full and everything stopped
they all stopped proliferating they
don't overcrowd and they suddenly start
acting as a hyper intelligent being and
the quorum starts to do things that you
would never expect from a single
bacteria and this is what we see
happening as you reconnect a cancer cell
it suddenly realized it's part of a 70
trillion cell
quorum and it literally does the silent
suicide moment it just apatow says it
says oh thank god zach still here
zach still here oh my god I thought he
was dead I'm so glad he's alive that's
[ __ ] beautiful I'm just gonna go to
sleep now I was so damaged I was so
freaking tired to begin with I'm just so
damaged on this old vulnerable cell I'm
so glad Zach's good I'm gonna kill
myself so it goes through this app
Atossa thing and of course I do need
another kid you cells so the stem cell
comes in and makes me a new kidney cell
there I never knew I aim and had cancer
but the microbiome reconnected to that
cancer cell
this they threw how does it reconnect it
through this matrix is liquid circuit
board of intelligence that's made by the
microbiome and so now we have to like we
have to zoom forward for a moment cuz I
got to leave you guys all with with some
really depressing news and I apologize
that but I all of this sounds like an
interesting thought experiment all this
so far sounds like oh that's kind of
weird mind blowing I don't I will never
be able to communicate any of that that
he just said to anybody I know and
that's too bad cuz it sounded kind of
cool but I want to tell you what we've
done to the microbiome and as the liquid
circuit board collapsed I want you to
tell you we're Homo sapiens sapiens
right now because we've gotten pictures
of it all weekend as our First Nation
people sitting in the back here have
told us their peoples are dying of
suicide at an extreme rate the cancer
cells of an isolated human being when it
commits suicide is a graceful event it
is them saying I'm the cancer so I'm so
damaged I cannot repair anymore I'm so
hurt I'm gonna get out of the way for
the rest of humanity
that's an isolated should be cancer cell
but instead of going and doing a school
shooting it says I'm just gonna get out
of the way I'm gonna I'm gonna commit
suicide we've been talking about suicide
here tonight and throughout the weekend
I would just anybody who has lost
somebody to suicide I want you to know
that that person was trying to do what
they thought was the most graceful exit
they could they were trying to get
themselves out of way for life to happen
they had lost track they were so
disconnected and I know that it was a
selfish act and the devastated everybody
else around them and I know all of that
but just know that it was the most
altruistic thing that they could do from
that position of damage and loneliness
in a very bizarre way suicide is an a
scream for love into the universe around
us it isn't I love you even though I
can't love you or
I love you so much that I'm gonna get
out of the way that's the mentality of
this cell that and I want you to know
the state of where we are so that we can
start to tap into consciousness and lose
the concept in the end hubris of human
consciousness and just start to see
consciousness rising on the planet we
have so devastated through our farming
and agricultural and medical systems as
they have collided with their
antimicrobial behavior we have so
destroyed biology on earth at its core
level now that one in 30 children are
now born with or moving into shortly
after birth they will have an autism
injury one in 30 children that numbers
irrelevant to the human experience but
I'll tell you that in 1975 the year
before we created roundup before we
started infiltrating the entire soil
system of the earth with an anti
microbial one in 5,000 children had
autism one in 5,000 in 1975 to one in 30
today the steepest climb in this
autistic curve didn't happen in the 70s
when we maybe weren't quite as aware of
the condition because one in 5,000 kids
at the steepest is happening right now
we are doubling our rates of autism
every three years we are now at one in
30 we will be at one in 15 by the
mid-2020s here we are on track to have
one in three children in the United
States with an autism spectrum disorder
by 2035 which sounds a long ways off to
most of our brains but that's 15 years
to more American presidents and we could
have one in three children with autism
at the same rate we have seen 5x of ALS
ms celiac disease and then the other
neurodegenerative that we see it going
in the elderly Parkinson's and males
Alzheimer's and women 5x in the last
15-20 years we are becoming so
disconnected that biology is literally
collapsing beneath our feet my team from
our lab was just talking to the EPA a
couple weeks ago and we were showing
them data that is so
damming to round up we have shown them
that and this isn't just my lab we were
presenting all the data but a lot of
university labs have been doing this
work to show that if you inject a mouse
or rodent
with a little bit of roundup about the
amount you would see in a couple days of
nutritional consumption you injected it
under their skin they live a totally
normal life they don't have any injury
from it and so it must be a super safe
compound just injected right under the
skin right into their bloodstream
they're fine
but then if you follow their pups the
next generation is suddenly struck with
massive obesity immune dysfunction and
metabolic collapse a lot of lots of
stuff happening in the second generation
know roundup injury to that generation
they just sorry back down one generation
in it the third generation is born
stillborn severe dura birth defects or
or cancer within the first few months of
life the third generation of roundup
babies you know we really saturate our
food system in 1996 and so 24 years is
kind of the full generation and so you
can see by 2015 we see the second
generation being born of course in that
journey we were already seeing this
explosion of obesity and autoimmune
disease and everything we saw in the
mice but the third generation will be
born in this next few years the third
generation of humans born into the round
of error are upon us
they will look as the experiments have
all played out as the most damaged an
injured population we've ever seen we
are on the verge of the biggest
Holocaust that will ever happen to the
human species seven billion people will
be witness to one in three children with
autism seventy to eighty percent of our
adults with cancer at that moment and
the highest rates of infertility ever
seen
we've lost 57 percent of sperm counts in
all Western countries in just 40 years
sperm counts have dropped by 57% one in
three males is now infertile by sperm
count in Western nations if we do that
one more time we will reach an
extinction level of 90 95 percent
infertility crippled with the disease's
I've laid out for you what I just gave
you is an apology to this woman for
being such a pain in the ass and I'm
still talking to me yeah you're doing
your job we do have to round this up and
this is that is this is quite a
dystopian picture that you're painting
for us right here and I would like to
let everyone go tonight feeling feeling
a little bit hopeful so I know you have
words that you could share on that as
well so maybe we could hit it a little
bit here and land the plane I know you
have an advocate you guys have an
advocate here minutes thank you rich
thank you all for your patience and get
up and leave no problems no offense at
all if it wasn't the survival of our
species I wouldn't be torturing you and
those uncomfortable chairs right now but
what I just gave you what I just told
you is humanity has a terminal disease
and as you're almost piss doctor right
at the moment I would like to tell you
you have the best opportunity you've
ever had you're in your life to become
the most human you've ever been if we as
a human species step into this moment
and drop all of the stories we've been
telling each other some great stories
this weekend it's important to tell our
story it's important to know our history
but we don't transform we don't really
evolve past our story we can be defined
by our story we cannot transform and
evolve past our story until we let go of
it completely I just told you the story
of humanity as it's been written we
could believe that story and we could
just live by that and it will fall out
just as we've talked or we could
acknowledge the story and say we're
gonna let go of our identity we're gonna
let go of our belief systems we're gonna
let go of our behaviors and we're gonna
be willing to be a completely new blank
canvas to Planet Earth itself because in
the end what I have told you tonight is
human consciousness is not at all human
humanity I believe is at the center
point
of all of life on earth for the reason
that we've been given the opportunity to
be the CPU chip for the planet Mother
Earth is rising again in an
extraordinary moment of extinction 20
every 20 minutes and other species goes
extinct every 20 minutes we've lost 40%
of biology on earth in the last 50 years
we're almost halfway done with this
great extinction and you showed up right
the frick now 7 billion people showed up
right now at the tipping point of 200000
years of homo sapien to be a fresh
canvas and the leaders among us will be
the autistic children because when an
autistic kid is supported back to health
that kid can never be programmed with
the current paradigm they refuse they
don't even have the right wiring to
accept it and so I am asking every one
of you to look deep into yourself and
become as autistic as possible tonight
stop believing what the world wants you
to feel and feel real tonight because in
that if you are willing to really feel
what it's like to be human right now you
will feel agony you will feel pain you
will feel isolation you will feel
loneliness and you will feel
unbelievable hope and you will feel
unbelievable love percolating up through
mother earth or self which is saying
wake up you're on Hospice you've got six
months to live you have a terminal
diagnosis that cannot be cured and so
you need to let that body die and become
something new and so each of you will
participate in the biggest
transformation event that has ever
happened when you completely let go of
who you think you are today and talk to
the people who you love next to you and
say will you please bargain with me
today will you please sit down and
brainstorm with me today on how we can
be a completely different relationship
tomorrow I would like to have a
completely different relationship with
you rich tomorrow
I would like to just forget that we've
ever done podcast together I would like
to just let all those stories that have
caught people's attention before and
just look you deeper into the your
experience in your soul and say what
could create bigger what could we create
cleaner than what we've told before
because you and I are more beautiful
than we know and you and I could create
something more beautiful indeed in just
our love for one another and we could
just let all of the beliefs of what if
you weren't rich role at all what if we
stopped calling you rich what if you
stop seeing me as Zack and what if we
just said holy human being you are so
glorious thank you for being with me
thank you for sharing this evening with
me I would like to finish it with
another hug we could do that thank you
you